foreign
quick question I Love Lucy do you love I
love oh boy yeah I mean I've always I
have the box set at home I grew up with
it do you still have a DVD player I do I
know I'm a big fan of DVDs so I mean you
know but some of the stuff I can't find
anymore start watching I Love Lucy at
home I had no choice I was at home was
my mom and sisters and they loved I Love
Lucy so I loved I Love Lucy and it was a
great show and also you know to see a
Latino as a lead actor on the show that
was a big deal for me to see that you
know
um
you know
yeah Ricky Ricardo was pretty amazing
and Lucy obviously what they did
together so okay so something that
really intrigues me about you and if you
don't mind talking about it is the fact
that you grew up with a mother and three
sisters right yeah how did it form you
what is your life experience from
growing up in a house full of women
first of all how a tiny apartment in the
Lower East Side Right four of us one
bathroom yes
um that's a big deal you have to
understand that I never and I was the
youngest I never got access to that
bathroom
haha
I'd be like late to school you know my
sister would come out in like a plume of
smoke like a steam room she'd been there
for 45 minutes you know so like there's
a there's a lot of things that I that
I'm very grateful for to grow up in a
home like that uh there's a sensitivity
obviously there's a communication and
again we might have not had a lot but
there was a whole lot of love that is
without a doubt you know if there was
you know if something there was a rift
between one of us
there was no like doors slamming because
there was only one bedroom so I was like
you kind of had to deal with it in the
apartment you kind of had and to watch
my mom
as a single woman raise us in a in a you
know it was rough back then that
neighborhood and to see what she went
through I would see her I'd seen her go
down to the street where you know there
were people selling drugs and someone
sold drugs to my sister she went right
up to that guy very very big guy and she
was like don't you ever
so like this little woman and the power
that she had and sort of protecting her
tribe it really there was a lot of
respect and love that I gained from that
experience and there's things that you I
wish I didn't have to see and experience
as before in that apartment you know
like everyone going through their
menstrual cycle the emotional craziness
but I had to navigate it okay this show
of yours Ramon that is just off the
charts everybody's talking about it will
Trent
um you know you solve crimes you end up
with this the cutest little dog on the
planet
um you know seen stealer that's amazing
totally I love her and like who doesn't
want a cute guy with an adorable dog
it's like let's just sell this fantasy
even more you know there's romance it
like has it all if you were to solve a
crime in your real life what crime would
you be best solving would it be crazy
like murder
or entering and breaking which is not
how
money laundering
um what would be I mean those are some
high stakes high stakes crime yeah well
maybe breaking and entering I feel like
there's a bit of uh you know sort of
following the breadcrumb trailing and
sort of trying to put the pieces
together and you know get that's
something growing up in my one of the
things in my apartment like we didn't
have a lot of space I had my little sort
of corner and that was my it's like
don't add to my swiss but I could see
everything some of my sisters were a
mess but we had to live with it you know
everyone's a different personality but I
think putting together things and
telling the story I enjoy that process
um maybe also why we do what we do which
is sort of putting together stories yeah
and narratives and so that's also what
will Trent is very good at he can sort
of look at things because he's dyslexic
he can look at things visually and he
picks up on things other people might
miss and he can create a narrative in
his story to try to help solve a crime
and will Trent is that so yeah it's
delicious oh my gosh speaking of
delicious Ramon is it true that you are
like Bagel obsessed I love a bagel you
kidding you yes
um all right well we're celebrating
Pizza through the show and since you
love Bagels did you hear that pizza and
bagel had a baby and there is such a
thing as a pizza bagel
um
listen I like that you don't think this
is a good idea I don't know I'm like the
pizza's the pizza the bagels The Bagel
they that should they have babies well
it's not supposed to happen will you
taste the babies
okay good yes
yeah it's a ginormous pizza bagel made
by Utopia pizza bagel I feel like that's
a that's quite a name yeah they're not
high standard the expectations yeah I
hope you like it pizza bagel they're
like Utopia right pizza you're going to
Utopia if you have this delicious thing
I mean okay all right here all right
here let me get you hold on wait oh wow
this is I don't know if this is big
enough for me I'm not sure
[Applause]
we should do this thing
all right here we go ready one two three
foreign
I mean
for oppression that wasn't into it I'm
actually kind of into it it's
interesting I like the crust have you
tried the crust yet oh of course well
but I I think it's wonderful and we love
Utopia pizza bagel and if you are open
to a pizza and a bagel having a baby
this is the most amazing version of that
and if you're a purit
then you can do that too yeah thank you
Utopia Bagel thank you
um Ross is actually in the kitchen he's
about to like whip up some other like
pizza something
all right we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign